good evening from time to time the Board
of Governors of the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences decides to
bestow the Irving Thalberg award upon a
filmmaker whose body of work has been
deemed outstanding perhaps it can be
said that the young Irving Thalberg was
the main architect of Hollywood's golden
age whatever color the movies are now is
due in great part to the prodigious
talents and the enormous influence of
still another young filmmaker tonight
the Board of Governors of the Academy
presents the Irving Thalberg award to a
man who does full honor to the list of
those who have received it before him he
stands in mid-career and yet he has
already achieved an astounding body of
work and hundreds of millions of
moviegoers all over the world are
waiting eagerly to go wherever he
decides to lead them ladies and
gentlemen Steven Spielberg
thank you second I'm resisting like
crazy to use Sally Fields wine from two
years ago
thank you very much following in the
footsteps of some of my heroes sessile B
DeMille and George Stevens Alfred
Hitchcock William Wyler bigmar Bergman
and Robert Wise this award is truly a
great honor for me the Thalberg award
was first given 50 years ago in 1937
which was the year of an old Chicago
Captains Courageous dead end the life of
Emile Zola Lost Horizon Stage Door and a
star is born all having been nominated
for Best Picture that year I'm told
Irving Thalberg worship writers and
that's where it all begins that we are
first and foremost storytellers and
without as he called it the photo play
everybody is simply improvising he also
knew that a script is more than just a
blueprint that the whole idea of movie
magic is that interweave of powerful
image and dialogue and performance and
music that can never be separated and
when it's working right can never be
duplicated or ever forgotten I've grown
up most of my life has been spent in the
dark watching movies movies have been
the literature of my life the literature
of Irving Thalberg his generation was
books and plays they read the great
words of great minds and I think in our
romance with technology and our
excitement at exploring all the
possibilities of film and video
I think we've partially lost something
that we now have to
Swayne I think it's time to renew our
romance with the word I'm as culpable as
anyone and having exalted the image of
the word of the expense of the image
exalted exalting the image of the
expense of the word but only a
generation of readers will spawn a
generation of writers the five films
nominated for Best Picture this year are
as much the writers film as the
directors and it's good news that each
of these films has found its audience
because this audience who we all work
for deserves everything we have to give
them they deserve that fifth draft that
tends to take that one extra cut and
those several dollars over budget and
Irving Thalberg knew that he would have
been proud to have been associated with
any of these films as I'm proud to have
my name on this award in his honor
because it reminds me of really how much
growth is an artist I have ahead of me
in order to be worthy of standing in the
company of those who have received this
before me so my deepest thanks to the
Board of Governors of the Academy and
the audience out there in the dark thank
you very much